TWO BEDROCK PRINCIPLES AGAINST
EACH OTHER, THE GOVERNMENTS NEED
TO PRESERVE SECRECY AGAINST A
REPORTER'S FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
BRET?
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
LET'S GET MORE ON HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ACTIONS COULD
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
JOURNALISTS AND THEIR SOURCES.
HERE IS FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST
AND THE HOST OF THE MEDIA BUZZ,
HOWARD KURTZ.
>> Reporter: THE DISCLOSURE
ABOUT "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER
ALI WATKIN SET OFF ALARM BELLS
IN THE NEWS BUSINESS AS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS WILLING TO
OBTAIN A JOURNALISTS PHONE AND
EMAIL RECORDS IN PURSUIT OF
LEAKS.
REPRESS ADVOCATES ARE BACKING
THE PAPER SAYING THE MOVE WILL
ENDANGER REPORTER'S ABILITY TO
PROMISE CONFIDENTIALITY TO THEIR
SOURCES AND MAKE IT HARDER TO
SHINE A MUCH NEEDED LIGHT ON
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS.
BUT THE CASE IS COMPLICATED BY
WATKINS' THREE YEAR ROMANTIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH JAMES WOLF WHO
WAS ARRESTED YESTERDAY.
SHE WAS A REPORTER FOR BUZZFEED
WHEN SHE BROKE THE STORY LAST
YEAR ON CARTER PAGE, A FORMER
TRUMP ADVISOR MET WITH A RUSSIAN
SPY.
WATKINS AND WOLF EXCHANGE 124
ELECTRONIC MESSAGES THAT DAY,
THE INDICTMENT SAID.
THIS BOOK FOR 7 MINUTES AFTER
THE STORY WAS POSTED AND ANOTHER
15 MINUTES AFTER SHE APPEARED ON
MSNBC.
>> WHY DID CARTER PAGE CONFIRM
THIS TO YOU, AND WHAT WAS HIS
AFFECTS TOWARDS THIS INFORMATION
AND BEING PUBLIC?
>> HE WAS VERY FORTHCOMING WITH
IT.
I HAD BEEN DOING A LOT OF
REPORTING ON IT SO I KNEW THAT
IT WAS HIM IN THE DOCUMENT.
>> WOLF TEXTED HER MONTHS LATER
THAT, I ALWAYS TRY TO GIVE YOU
THE INFORMATION YOU NEED IT SO
YOU COULD GET THE SCOOP BEFORE
ANYONE ELSE.
I FELT LIKE I WAS PART OF YOUR
EXCITEMENT.
SHE HAS DENIED RECEIVING LEAKS
FROM WOLF.
ERIC HOLDER SECRETLY OBTAINED
RECORDS FROM AP STAFFERS AND
FROM FORMER FOX CORRESPONDENT
JAMES ROSEN IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
SAYS HE'S CONDUCTING THREE TIMES
AS MANY INVESTIGATIONS.
>> I HAVE THIS MORNING FOR
WOULD-BE LEAKERS, DON'T DO IT.
FOR THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS, WE
HAVE ALREADY MADE CHANGES AND
ARE SERIOUSLY RAMPING UP OUR
EFFORTS.
>> BE ON THE PERSONAL DETAILS
FOR ALI WATKIN'S, FOR
PROSECUTORS TO GO AFTER
REPORTER'S RECORDS AND ENCRYPTED
APPS STRIKE AT THE HEART OF